the great Anthony Daniels played c-3po I
think we have a still from him on the
set of the original Star Wars did you
get any advice from him about playing
you know an iconic Star Wars droid I did
he came to the set while we were
shooting and I met him I went up and met
him and said I was I was a droid and he
knew of me the small club and it is cool
it's like your guys that played James
Bond there's only a couple of you
that's fantastic yeah bb-8 so drunk so
you can't really I've seen bb-8 be
tossed out of clubs yeah yeah just rolls
away yeah I loved his early work on cast
away but c-3po said definitely Daniels
went on about the the shoot that he had
to wear and that they didn't originally
they put screws in my head you know they
closed it and he had to be on this thing
and he said wait a minute are you are
you wearing a actual robot costume were
they doing it in motion capture I said
motion capture
he said you [ __ ] then I saw him at the
premiere and I said hello again and I
said I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you for
notes when this is over so if you could
please tell me how I did and I saw him
at the party afterwards and he came up
and said you and that's one of the best
compliments
I'm kind of the c-3po voice yeah
[Applause]
you